bonjour et bienvenue au coeur du
parlement européen à bruxelles pour
l'émission europe hebdo
cette semaine on s'intéresse à
l'illettrisme ce fléau caché touche près
d'un européen sur sept et notamment les
pays en crise
reportage au portugal mais tout de suite
la question d'actualité
l'europe est-elle projet m
en europe les polémiques se suivent et
se ressemblent après l' agence
européenne du médicament et la sphère
médiator c'est au tour de l' agence de
sécurité des aliments d'être accusé de
collusion avec les producteurs
d'organismes génétiquement modifiés
la faute à l'avis rendu sur l'étude du
professeur séralini et la toxicité des
ogm en septembre dernier son laboratoire
met les pieds dans le plat tumeur
mammaire nécrose du foie inflammation
rénale mortalité prématurée des rongeurs
les ogm serait mauvais pour la santé
sans blague mais l'étude et controversé
et les critiques pleuvent mauvaise foi
et fautes professionnelles pour séralini
qui voit la main mise des producteurs
sur les scientifiques c'est la guerre de
position ils y allaient pour et il y
aller contre jusqu'aux autorités
sanitaires qui une à une des montes la
méthodologie utilisée par le laboratoire
sauf que ces agences sont régulièrement
pointés du doigt pour leur liens
incestueux avec les industriels pour
preuve la présidente de l' agence de
sécurité des aliments a quitté ses
fonctions il ya quelques mois pour
prendre la tête du lobby de l'industrie
agro alimentaire
alors bruxelles projet
alors nous sommes sur ce plateau avec
michèle rivasi bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne française vous êtes du groupe
des verts on pose une question
volontairement provocante mais ce qu'on
peut dire que bruxelles et en
l'occurrence donc la commission
européenne serait selon vous projet m
bah écoutez la commission oui et projet
m par contre c'est fort possible que ça
commence mais parce que plusieurs fois
ils ont autorisé justement du maïs
transgénique
et puis on s'aperçoit que il n'y avait
pas les études qui allait de pair c'est
pour ça qu'avec un certain nombre de
députés par rapport à l'étude de ces
rallyes n'est que vous avez mentionné
dans votre reportage on a dit ya quand
même des choses qui vont pas lagence
lève sa fille et celle agence qui dit
oui ou non est ce que les études sont
conformes par rapport à un cahier des
charges mais ce cahier des charges ne va
pas puisque on n'a pas des études sur le
long terme
oui c'est sur trois mois ou à la limite
bon c'est 90 jours mais c'est même pas
obligatoire
après lorsqu'on va avoir toutes les
données faites par les industriels qui
demandent l'autorisation
elles ne sont pas publiques on les a pas
sur internet donc on a profité de ça
pour dire quelle que soit l'étude de
séralini de toute façon elles m'ont des
dysfonctionnements sur le protocole
employés par l' agence c'est une boîte
et du doigt pour bien comprendre c'est
un manque de transparence
mais l'étude du professeur séralini dont
vous parlez là où il s'agissait des rats
avec cet humain a été je dirais pas être
unanimement mais elle a été en tout cas
beaucoup critiqué y compris
effectivement par les autorités
européennes
donc est ce que ça veut dire que sur le
fond l'europe et je reviens à ma
question président propres ogm ou des
non c'est juste un manque de
transparence dans la façon de faire arie
deux choses d'abord l'europe et projet m
vous savez qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya
plein de maïs par exemple où les états
ne sont pas d'accord pour donner
l'autorisation
or s'il n'ya pas l'unanimité c'est la
commission qui décide et à l'heure
actuelle est à peu près 7
si vous voulez maïs qui sont en cours
d'autorisation
c'est la commission qui dit oui on va
les autoriser bon ça c'est une première
chose après la deuxième chose c'est
qu'ils donnent l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché
c'est une agent sanitaire qui s'appelle
l'efsa et suite à l'étude de ces à
lennik a été très fortement critiquée ça
a quand même mis en évidence qu'il ya
des dysfonctionnements sur la façon dont
on autorise ces maïs ou soja ou où cette
pomme de terre par exemple qui peut être
en génie c'est ça qui va pas c'est qu'il
n'est pas normal qu'on étudie ça que sur
une laps de temps trop court
il n'est pas normal que tout le monde
n'ait pas accès aux données il n'est pas
normal que toutes les études soient
faites par l'industriel pour autoriser
si l'industriel cache des données
et bien c'est très difficile pour les
expériences dépendante de le voir et en
même temps lève ça a été plusieurs fois
attaqué confit d'intérêt avec
l'association la présidente de l'efsa
démissionner avant l'été dernier
justement parce qu'elle était on va dire
soupçonné de conflit d'intérêts et juste
après cette démission elle a été
travaillé dans le principal lobby des
ogm
ça c'était il ya quelques mois
aujourd'hui ce que vous diriez que le
ménage a été fait à l'efsa écoutez le
ménage est en cours
parce que en tant que député européen on
peut ne plus voter les subventions
c'est ce qu'on a fait récemment mais je
dis que tous les conflits sont pas
réglés toutes les agences que se soit
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
même à onze j'ai beaucoup travaillé où
on a fait démissionner des personnes qui
étaient en conflit d'intérêts que ce
soit l'efsa qui a un rôle essentiel sur
les ogm comme sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens
voyez comme sur toutes les substances
chimiques qui peuvent le toucher
et bien c'est pas clair il ya encore
trop de conflits d'intérêts et il faut
faire le ménage au niveau de ses agences
alors puisqu'on parle de démission il ya
eu aussi une démission à la commission
européenne du commissaire qui s'occupait
entre autres des affaires de santé et
des affaires liées aux ogm à nouveau
commissaire a été nommé ce que là aussi
vous n'avez que les choses vont dans le
bon sens alors écoutez cette affaire
dany c'est le nom john dalli cern ont eu
connaissance
moi j'avoue que ça me laisse perplexe
perplexe parce que
il ya une enquête effectivement par
l'olaf quel office si vous voulez
contrôle européen
voilà la répression des fraudes en
quelque sorte et je trouve que le
président de la commission est allé très
vite en besogne
c'est à dire qu'il lui a demandé de
démissionner en dix minutes il devait
démissionner et quand on a regardé le
rapport bien il ya beaucoup de
d'allégations il ya beaucoup de
présomptions si vous voulez mais pas de
preuve alors nous on demande deux choses
on demande la transparence du rapport de
l'olaf concernant ce commissaire dany
est la deuxième personne ne l'a vu
personne l'a eu
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'on demande
à monsieur barroso de s'expliquer parce
que nos parlementaires on a voté le
candidat monsieur dali et lorsque on ne
démissionne
on n'a pas eu de compte rendu de la part
de monsieur barroso
donc on veut des explications claires
pourquoi il a fait démissionner quelles
sont les preuves qui ont fait que
monsieur dali et démissionner parce que
moi la question que je me pose c'est à
qui profite le crime
il ya pour l'instant le cri profite à
l'industrie du tabac puisqu'il y avait
une directive du tabac qui était dans
les tuyaux et qui a été bloqué par le
fait de la démission du sud est donc
vous pensez comme le principal intéressé
d'ailleurs john dalli parce que c'est ce
qu'il dit que finalement il aurait été
victime des industriels du tabac
alors écoutez je n'ai pas l'épreuve mais
je me dis que c'est quand même bizarre
que malte est un petit pays ont dit à
dali de partir comme ça on n'a pas de
preuves pour dire qu'il a fait une faute
exemplaire qui fait qu on a démissionné
imaginez que ça soit messieurs singer
commissaire allemand où monsieur barnier
commissaire et représentant de la france
je veux dire ça aurait fait un scandale
donc ce que j'aime pas c'est qu'on a on
nous a jamais donné une explication
tangible sur la démission missionnaire
alors après les ogm est un autre sujet
qui est très concernant pour nous tous
ça c'est celui des téléphones portables
au mois d'octobre
en italie il ya eu pour la première fois
en europe la cour de cassation qui a
reconnu qu'un homme qui s'appelle
inocente marcolini a été victime d'une
tumeur du
un usage intensif du téléphone portable
on va en parler dans un instant avec
vous mais d'abord on écoute sur
l'interview j'ai une douleur constante
24 heures sur 24
ici dans cette partie je crois que les
téléphones portables entre dans la liste
des dangers potentiels qui sont la cause
des tumeurs cérébrales
les téléphones sont probablement les
instruments les plus polluants que l'on
utilise à cause de la proximité de
l'appareil lors de l'utilisation
il y a de plus en plus de tumeurs
cérébrales en particulier les tumeurs
malignes qui se produisent suite à
l'utilisation des téléphones portables
il est humeur augmente chez les jeunes
voilà pour cette interview
dinnosanté marcolini avec quelques
officiels italiens des interviews
recueillies par la rai est ce que vous
diriez que sur les téléphones portables
on risquerait d'aller dans un scandale
qui serait proche par exemple de celui
de l'amiante mais écoutez il ya plein
indices qui montrent que l'utilisation
intensive du téléphone portable et mais
le cas de monsieur marcolini est
exemplaire montrent qu'il ya bien une
relation de cause à effet alors une
présomption de preuves entre le fait
d'utiliser massivement son portable et
d'avoir une tumeur au cerveau
moi ce que je condamne c'est que les
opérateurs et les politiques noté
l'opérateur de téléphonie de téléphonie
mobile ne font pas une information pour
dire aux consommateurs
attention le portable c'est pas un objet
banal c'est un objet à risque plus on
l'utilisé plus vous avez des ddd risque
de déclencher un cancer et notamment au
niveau des enfants il va y avoir la
période de noël
il faut pas que les mamans parce
qu'elles sont anxieuses achète un
portable à leurs enfants
plus on est jeune plus il ya des risques
de déclencher des cancers si vous voulez
il ya tellement de milliards véhiculée
par les opérateurs téléphonie mobile que
l'on nie complètement les risques mais
la tijâniyya scène j'ai envie de dire on
est un petit peu comme sur les
les ogm il ya eu des études qui ont été
faites
maintenant on a un certain recul puisque
le téléphone portable existe depuis une
vingtaine d'années et aucune de ces
études n'a dit clairement que le danger
était présent alors écoutez il ya une
étude qui s'appelle légumes bio
initiative qui a été publiée par
l'agencé européenne de l'environnement
et qui montre les risques les équipes
qui montent qui a pas de risque souvent
elles sont financées par les opérateurs
mais c'est comme l'histoire des ogm
il ya énormément de conflit d'intérêts
moi toutes les études y ait eu plus de
1500 étude publiée par l' agence
européenne qui montrent qu' il ya des
risques au niveau du cerveau il ya des
risques hormonaux il ya des risques au
niveau de l'adn
alors il faut comme la mort voyez
l'amiante c'était la même chose il y
avait un comité permanent où il y avait
plus de d'industriels avec des experts
financées par les industriels que deux
médecins capables de le dénoncer et ben
on est dans le même cas de figure donc
l'exemple de ceux de monsieur mark oline
qui est un cadre qui utilisait son
portable par rapport à sa profession
et bien cette personne a développé une
tumeur et ce qui est important c'est que
là le responsable c'est l'opérateur
téléphonie mobile et moi je lance un cri
de 2 g de dire et de l'information au
niveau de la population française en
disant attention n'achetez pas de
portable pour vos enfants
dites à vos ados d'utiliser le sms
prenez un kit oreillette mais ne pensez
pas que le portable
c'est un objet manade qu'on met
facilement au niveau du cerveau au delà
de l'information évidemment qui est qui
est importante si le téléphone portable
est aussi dangereux que que vous le
dites ça veut dire que il va y avoir des
centaines peut-être des milliers voire
plus de personnes qui vont développer
des tumeurs
est-ce que vous avez une possibilité
d'action j'ai envie de dire au parlement
européen et vous en particulier qui
serait par exemple du domaine légal
alors ce que je fais sur le parlement
européen c'est de dire il ya une
recommandation européenne qu'il faut il
faut réduire les champs
électromagnétiques parce qu'ils sont
beaucoup trop hauts et qu'en plus il
faut reconnaître
l'électrohypersensibilité et il faut
réduire au niveau de chaque état membre
si vous voulez les champs parce que y'a
le portable mais il ya aussi les
antennes relais et les ondes de la
téléphonie mobile c'est dénombre pulsé
qui ont un an
sanitaires plus important que les autres
par exemple de la télévision ou des
relais au niveau de la radio donc c'est
vraiment je suis en train de pousser le
parlement européen et la commission pour
que elle légifère et qui est une
harmonisation sur le plan européen
ce qui n'est pas le cas mais en même
temps il faut faire l'information au
niveau des consommateurs
michèle rivasi merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation va rester
évidemment dans le domaine européen et
nous allons parler de l'illettrisme en
europe dans quelques instants
kathia gilder en parlera avec son invité
mais nous allons tout de suite partir au
portugal en fait il ya en europe 75
millions de personnes qui sont victimes
d'illettrisme et au portugal c'est assez
marquée puisque dans ce pays
et bien c'est 10 % de plus que la
moyenne européenne
regardez ce reportage il est signé
sandra cerqueira écrire un geste
familier que certains dans l'enfance
n'ont jamais vraiment apprivoiser nous
sommes dans ce qu'on appelle au portugal
un centre des nouvelles opportunités
créées avec le soutien du fonds social
européen des cours du soir pour remettre
un niveau ceux qui ont quitté l'école
trop tôt
la plupart dans cette place ils sont
restés moins de 6 ans valence était mort
j'ai grandi dans une famille de sept
enfants
les frères ne sont allés à l'école
primaire et mon père m'a dit que même si
j'étais le plus jeune je ne pouvais pas
étudié plus il faut plus qu'un
renflouement
ils ont entre 40 et 50 ans et
réapprennent aujourd'hui ce qui nous
semble à tous être des acquis au
portugal 72 % des actifs n'ont pas
fréquenté le secondaire
j'ai arrêté l'école à 12 ans il y avait
un trop grand fossé entre moi et les
jeunes générations y compris avec mes
filles
j'étais dépassé par les connaissances
actuelles et j'ai ressenti le besoin de
reprendre les études
une telle tâche plus simple certains
rencontrent des difficultés au début
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les connaissances
de base suffisante
ils ont perdu l'habitude d'écrire et de
lire la moitié de la population active
du pays a quitté l'école à 14 15 ans en
trois ans la fréquentation du centre a
doublé louise vient d'arriver pour
constituer un dossier et suivre des
cours
il a commencé à travailler à 14 ans dans
la vente aujourd'hui au chômage
il ne pensait pas qu'un jour le manque
d'études serait un handicap
waouh il y a deux ans j'ai perdu un
emploi parce que je n'étais même pas
aller au collège
ces adultes qui arrivent ici ont tous
entre 40 50 ans ils ont travaillé dans
la même entreprise depuis qu'ils sont
tout jeunes et quand ils se retrouvent
au chômage
ils ont de l'expérience certes mais le
manque de qualification leur est
vraiment fatale
d'emblée ils sont exclus du marché du
travail
le portugal mauvais élèves de l'europe
mais dans le reste de l'union aussi lire
et écrire sans peine n'est pas une
évidence un tiers de la population
active est peu ou pas qualifiés et
concernant les plus jeunes générations
les chiffres ne sont guère meilleures
20% des jeunes sortent de l'école sans
avoir acquis le niveau de compétence
minimum le portugal connaît là encore le
taux le plus élevé d'europe 30%
d'abandon scolaire chez les jeunes dans
cette école de la deuxième chance
la seule du pays les élèves n'ont pas
étudié plus que leurs parents quand ils
arrivent ici ils ont arrêté les cours
depuis de nombreuses années
chaque jour paulo participent aux cours
de cuisine pour réapprendre à travailler
en groupe ils préparent ensemble le
déjeuner pour toute l'école
il a 23 ans et n'est même pas allé au
collège c'est pour travailler et aider
sa famille qu'il a décidé d'arrêter les
études l'école envoyé des lettres à mes
parents pour dire j'y allais plus mais
ça n'a servi à rien depuis j'ai cherché
du travail je n'ai rien trouvé
je pensais que d'arrêter l'école à 15
ans n'empêcherait pas de travailler dans
la restauration
souvent les jeunes portugais décroche
faute d'encadrement familial
c'est l'héritage de la dictature
salazariste qui négligea pendant 40 ans
l'éducation des masses ici on est plus
que des formateurs
on remplace la famille les parents
quitté l'école si jeune favorise
l'exclusion sociale on leur apprend à
retrouver un cadre c'est important pour
eux pour la suite
faute de moyens l'école a failli fermer
l'an passé le directeur se dit inquiet
car les demandes d'inscription ne cesse
d'augmenter
le portugal est dans une situation
économique très difficile en toute façon
on ne peut pas se passer de cette jeune
génération parce que nous avons l'une
des populations les plus vieillissante
d'oran incontestablement l'illettrisme
est une entrave à la croissance
un vrai handicap pour la compétitivité
le pays doit faire les efforts
nécessaires pour que les qualifications
augmente nous n'avons pas d'autre choix
d'autant que le pays possède également
le taux de scolarisation dans le
supérieur le plus faible de l'union
européenne pourtant dans dix ans
seulement 15% des emplois seront
destinés aux basses qualification
retour à bruxelles nous sommes avec
karima delli bonjour je députée
européenne et vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires sociales et de
l'emploi et vous travaillé notamment sur
la question de l'exclusion
est-ce que ce que l'on a vu dans ce
reportage la réalité de ces personnes en
situation d'illettrisme vous étonne des
situations au coeur de l'europe au
portugal
or cette situation ne m'étonne pas ce
que je connais le sujet et c'est là le
drame c'est à dire que la question de
l'illettrisme aujourd'hui devenue une
question taboue pour les états alors
qu'elle devrait être une priorité
politique on ne peut pas laisser en
europe 75 millions de personnes qui sont
notamment dans cette situation
d'illettrisme ça fait presque un
européen sur cinq
ça fait 1 européen sur sept et quand on
regarde les chiffres notamment des
jeunes
ça ça explose ce n'est pas normal qu'on
laisse 13 % des 15-24 ans sans aucun ni
empoigne apprentissage sans aucune
formation qui justes permettent d'avoir
les éléments de la vie parce que ce que
vous dites est ce que dit très bien
votre reportage c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
y les tris aura des conséquences
terribles
elles seront terribles sur l'emploi
parce que malheureusement aujourd'hui si
nous n'avons pas de bonnes bases de
qualification on a des réponses
répercussions sur l'emploi et surtout
l'illétrisme et moi je me je travaille
beaucoup sur l'exclusion et la pauvreté
a une conséquence directe sur les
questions de pauvreté alors on va juste
préciser l'illettrisme c'est le fait de
ne pas maîtriser des connaissances de
base lire écrire compter des
connaissances qui permet d'être autonome
dans la dans la vie quotidienne ce qui
est différent de l'analphabétisme
quels sont pour vous les causes de ce
phénomène un peu un peu caché finalement
est-ce qu'on a honte parfois de dire
qu'on est illettrée quelles sont les
causes est ce que c'est dû à un échec
scolaire est ce que c'est
c'est dû à un problème de formation qui
responsable je pense que d'abord c'est
l'ensemble des politiques publiques donc
des états qui sont responsables parce
qu'on a laissé justement sous le tapis
cette cette question qui devrait être
prioritaire ça c'est la première chose
dit qu'il devrait pas y avoir
d'illettrés dans les pays européens en
deux fait justement lutter contre ce
fléau et pour ça il faut en faire une
priorité la deuxième chose c'est qu'il a
fallu attendre septembre pour avoir un
rapport de l'ensemble est le constat qui
accable malheureusement l'europe sur ces
thématiques a aujourd'hui la véritable
question c'est à dire nous ne pouvons
plus aujourd'hui réellement juste des
déclarations il faut des actes alors
qu'elle a justement vous qui êtes
députée européenne qui travailler sur le
terrain qui rencontraient des acteurs
qu'elle quel type d'action faut-il
engagé à quel niveau haut niveau alors
c'est à dire il faut faire au niveau
européen au niveau national comme au
niveau local
ces trois niveaux sont nécessaires d'une
part il faut et le reportage le dit bien
il faut aider les parents aider les
parents pour que eux mêmes ont les
compétences pour qu'il donne envie à
leurs enfants de - 0
eh bien on peut mettre en place
notamment par exemple des structures qui
permettent d'apprendre à lire et à
écrire parce que justement aujourd'hui
si vous ne savez pas lire ni écrire pour
trouver un emploi pour faire vos courses
pour payer une facture c'est tout est
difficile vous n'êtes plus autonome ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose qu'il faut renforcer serainement
l'accompagnement social des enfants
notamment renforcé des petits groupes
pour que justement ils prennent le temps
qu'ils qui font en sorte d'améliorer
leurs compétences ça c'est la deuxième
chose est la troisième chose vraiment
qui moi me paraît important c'est
d'utiliser les fonds européens qui sont
souvent mal utilisés pour faire
notamment des
une véritable qualification un
apprentissage pour l'ensemble des ces
jeunes qui sortent justement de ces un
système scolaire sans rien c'est
souhaitable mais dans l'immédiat ce
qu'on constate c'est que parce qu'on a
vu au portugal le type d'action qui est
menée dans ce centre qui aide les
personnes illettrées à retrouver des
connaissances qui leur permettront
d'être autonome on a vu que ce centre il
était financé en partie par le fonds
social européen
or celui ci est quand même menacé de
disparition ou en tout cas menacé d'être
réduit à peau de chagrin
vu que les états ne se sont pas mis
d'accord sur le budget européen est ce
que ce fonds est menacé alors ce fonds
est menacée quand le l'ensemble des
fonds européens
mais le parlement européen a est en
codécision et le parlement européen dit
clairement nous mettrons nos bêtes notre
veto si l'ensemble des chefs d'état
décident de main de réduire à peau de
chagrin
justement notamment le fonds social le
gouvernement pour refuser que ce type de
fonds soient réduits il va la revoir là
comme il le fait par exemple sur les
aides alimentaires ou nous refusons
justement une réduction aujourd'hui le
but c'est dit il faut comprendre que les
politiques sociales
ce sont des investissements se sont pas
des dépenses nous le parlement européen
ne comprenons que la lutte contre la
pauvreté et l'exclusion dont l'huile est
restée partie est une priorité alors
justement il ya des acteurs qui comptent
sur votre action nous avons rencontré
une personne pour notre reportage au
portugal qui a une question directe à
vous poser une question qui s'adresse à
l'élue européenne que vous avez écouté
il est son objet développés europe s'est
fixé comme objectif de réduire d'ici
2020 à moins de 15% la part des jeunes
n'ayant pas acquis le niveau de
compétence minimum alors je demande
franchement responsables européens
qu'êtes vous réellement disposé à faire
quand on sait que pour atteindre cet
objectif il faut aider les pays les plus
touchés par la crise et ce sont ces pays
qui n'ont pas les moyens d' éradiquer
l'illettrisme
ils ont besoin d'être pour cela alors
comment les aider alors tout simplement
notamment en battant concernant les
jeunes aujourd'hui même on va mettre en
place une garantie jeunesse qui va
obligatoirement inciter les états à dire
qu'aucun jeunes sans formation sans qui
sortent du système scolaire
on doit au bout de quatre mois lui
proposer quelque chose nous dit on c'est
le parlement européen s'est fait c'est
la commission et le parlement européen
qui demande aux états que les états
s'engagent au bout de quatre mois à
apporter notamment à chaque jeune soit
une formation soit un emploi soit n'en
croise tisane ce sera là dans quelques
dans quelques jours c'est ce qu'on
appelle la garantie jeunesse dont on
parle des jeunes
il ya aussi des personnes on les a vus
dans ce reportage qui ont plus de 50 ans
qui sont moins jeunes en tout cas et qui
ont du mal à garder un travail pour
trouver un travail
qu'est-ce qu'on peut offrir qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez offrir comme perspective
comme travail à cette population là qui
parfois et même souvent et peu qualifiés
alors tu d'abord vous avez dit peu
qualifiés il faut savoir que l'ensemble
et des personnes peu qualifiées en
europe comme en france sont exclus du du
marché du travail ça il faut tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé parce qu'aujourd'hui
lorsque vous êtes par exemple non
diplômés au chômage ça représente 15%
alors que quand vous êtes diplômé c'est
seulement cinq pour ce qu'on peut les
aider à rentrer le chemin de
l'emploi à la foule pour ça il faut
d'une part les accompagner mais surtout
renforcer le dispositif notamment deux
formations pour ça ce n'est pas normal
par exemple quoi france 10 % des
chômeurs n'ont pas accès à une formation
notamment au pôle emploi parce que soit
ils n'ont pas la formation soit ils
n'ont pas réellement une formation qui
leur correspond où ça ce n'est pas une
formation d'avenir parfois ils ne savent
pas que tel type de dispositifs existent
voilà où alors on n'y a pas
d'information accessible contrairement à
nos voisins européens et ensuite
lorsqu'on parle de formation aujourd'hui
il faut investir dans des nouveaux
secteurs
on ne peut plus aujourd'hui regardez le
passé le monde a changé et ces secteurs
les secteurs d'avenir cse c'est ce que
moi j'appelle les secteurs les
éco-industries parce que souvent on a
tendance à croire que l'industrie au
delà est en panne y passe un étang pour
pour faire un exemple de secteur
d'avenir porteur l'agriculture d'espoir
pour ceux versés par exemple
l'agriculture biologique
aujourd'hui ce sont des emplois locaux
non délocalisables qui vont permettre
réellement d'engranger des milliers
d'emplois un autre secteur c'est la
rénovation thermique
aujourd'hui il va falloir rénové par
exemple en france des millions de
logements nous aurons besoin de me
d'emplois qualifiés est également peu
qualifiés c'est bon pour climat c'est
bon pouvoir d'achat c'est pas bon pour
pour l'emploi local
voilà bien merci le message bien compris
merci d'avoir été avec nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine à
strasbourg avec nora hamadi pour une
nouvelle édition d'europe et d'autres
très bonne semaine à tous ciao